where the heck did it go
do we have another flashlight a slice of
hot dog rolled under the refrigerator
there's a flashlight on mom's nightstand
[Music]
find the flashlight
yes
i also found this letter from caltech
i wonder why she was hiding it
so read it
i'm not allowed to it's not addressed to
me who cares the us postal service is a
government agency mail is protected by
federal law all right
don't if you do i'll be an accessory to
the crime
interesting
what does it say no don't tell me
okay tell me no don't sheldon if i tell
you but you never look at it then you
didn't break the law right
the offices of morris morris and your
janice speaking hello i'd like to speak
to either maurice morris or yarn
may i ask what it is in regard to well i
was slicing a hot dog if i don't
actually look at the letter legally i'm
in the clear
thank you this has been very helpful and
if in the future you have any physics
questions janice has my info
missy you can legally tell me what's in
the letter
see
here's where it gets fun come on
please
cheese
now tell me what was in that letter
you're pretty cranky for princess rodeo
clown missy caltech wants you to go to
school there
really they want to talk to mom and dad
about it
i can't believe she would hide that from
me whatever put your nose back on
i'm home
would you care to explain this letter
which i didn't read but legally know the
contents of
well
what were you doing going through my
nightstand you answered my question
first i am your mother and i don't need
to answer anything
how could you not tell me that caltech
wants me to go to school there because
you're not going so it doesn't matter so
what i'm gonna say in this
actually no which is why that letter is
addressed to the parents of sheldon
cooper
so dad was okay hiding this for me we
are done having this discussion go to
your room
hey what time does photomat close
i was angry at my mother and needed more
information
while she told me to go to my room she
didn't say stay there
boy howdy i do love a loophole
all right who's harder
cindy crawford
or jessica rabbit
once a person runs a cartoon and you
couldn't get either one of them no i
answered the question daddy
what the hell are you doing here i need
to talk to you
how'd you even find me it's not like you
come home smelling like coffee
what do you want sheldon i want to know
why no one told me about this
recruitment letter from caltech
let me see that
all right let's get me drunk hi mr
gibbons oh come on
[Music]
is